dea
今から日本語の熱戦を行う
今から東京楽しむためのアドバイスをいくつか紹介したいと思う
いちばん桜が咲いている時に是非来日してください
すれば日本人と同じように人が多くて花見を楽しく経験できないか経験できる
2番 jr のパースを買わない香りに意味
日本人と同じように法外な値段を電車に費やすことしたら東京に住んでる人と同じよう
にホーム恵さんが経験できる
いくらだったっけ3番東京駅で成田エキスプレス降りたときトイレ休憩が必要だろう
ホームのエスカレーターに乗って二階に上がってください右手に比較的に古いといれば
その奥に汚い和式トイレが一つ使ってください一番最初にそうすることによって残りの
時間がもっと楽しく経験できる
4番
最初の2日間は時差ぼけがひどいはせたすぐに街に出て無理やり人間竜巻楽しもうと
すればかえって失望するホテルでバイキングを食べてフェアで君の名はをみたほうが
無難だろう
5番視差ボケがなくなったら築地に行って寿司を食べる
計画を変えて日本人と同じようにマックにでエビバーガーを食べる
ことこうすることによって本当の東京生活を味わうことができる
ヒント直前に恋人に振られるとエビバーガーがもっとおいしくなる
b 6判富士山を登る香りに遠くから見ていつかを登ってみたいなとかこつけて言うし
たらすごいと言われ気持ちが高揚するならばスカイツリー
に入って2時間並んだ後第1展望台に行って
そんなに高くないんだ
かっ狩りするその後第二展望台に行って
高すぎてよくわからと再びがっかりすけパチ版がっかりした状態で駅に向かう
人ごみがひどい電車の中で別の電車に乗っている寂しそうな女性と目がお互いに運命を
感じると思ったら女性がビルに遮られ宇宙に消えてしまう
これが日本のわびさびだ9番ホテルでもう一度気味
の名はを見て東京楽しまなきゃという気持ちを高め
10番翌朝街に出て東京は戦後の莫大な冷たい金融街であり
東洋の近代的なディズニーランドではないとさ通り
深いうつに陥る11番気晴らしに横浜に行ってみる
するとみなとみらいは東洋の近代的なディズニーランドだと気づき残りの時間を測で
過ごす
ni